[Music]
we are 30 years into the show the most
popular daily show in the world it's
blown all of our minds it really is
amazing in 30 years it's just it's such
a huge milestone I'm so grateful to be
here it's exciting for me I get to work
with John and with Katherine Kelly Lange
who really set the tone for this show my
name is Eric I'm Brooke on day one it
was it was very exciting day there's a
lot of magic you could feel it it's
stunning that Kelly and I are still here
after the first year first day on on the
show was so exciting because I walk in
there and the sets are there the fourths
or living room is huge
all right that's mine that's my living
room it's playing in over a hundred
countries and 36 million people watch it
every single day we're doing 255
episodes every year and we've been to
Abu Dhabi and Italy we just came back
from Sydney Australia shooting in France
all around the world South Africa is
coming we went to Australia Dayton I
felt like the Beatles I felt like Ringo
and then John macaque was you know Paul
McCartney our show is about love and
it's about romance and we tackle some
big issues but at the end of the day you
know it's this little bonbon in the
middle of the afternoon where people can
just like enjoy someone else's drama
it's this nice little piece of candy
with a real chewy Center well the
beautiful is all about fashion and I
love fashion it's really great that we
get to wear things that are right off
the runway and we get to work with
designers like Monique Lhullier and have
these incredible gowns and feel like a
princess every day and then of course we
interlace it with you know love stories
and triangles and you know
fairs and whatever and people go yeah
you know I just fall in love with women
all week which is kind of nice it's kind
of like college a little bit and there's
no consequence ever which is again like
cards don't ask me Eric they were torn
so that's why it's a Forster Forster
force Forster and then back to Ridge
Forrester so really was there was many
foresters in there I think I marry Ridge
probably about ten times so you've got
Los Angeles right and it's this
beautiful glamorous place and then
behind the scenes all these people all
these billionaires and beautiful people
they're all messed up oh yeah man their
lives are no better than mine like I
want to watch I want to watch these
people just implode when Pearson found
out that Thomas was going to be having
sex with Caroline then soon to be
ridge's wife but to be my baby mama so
no big deal she was my girlfriend first
just saying what brad says is that every
scene is a love scene and so even when
you're arguing with someone even when
you are when they're your nemesis on the
show you're still it's still in love
scene at the core of the show it's about
families that the families that care
about one another and and that's
something that's very universal you're
not my sister mine you're not Maya at
all
I'm Myron she was the first transgender
character on both in the beautiful and
in daytime and actually to be a series
regular on network TV Rick you know
ended up falling in love with Maya who
was formerly known as Myron it was like
I don't care I just I just love her it
was lovely it was a really wonderful i
opening you know story and it caught the
attention of a lot of people oh we were
right there at the cutting edge of that
i was proud of our show not just for
doing it but we're doing it so well i
would love to write the show every day i
love going to the studio every day so
it's just it's been a grand adventure
what's one thing to be number one and
anything you do right you want to get
there you want to be the best to
maintain that over this amount of time
is extraordinary the most-watched
daytime show in the world
[Music]
you